nouvelle illustration du en même temps
cher au président de la République notre
pays a en effet réussi la performance
diplomatique d'être en froid et avec
l'Algérie et avec le Maroc le Maroc a
rappelé son ambassadeur à Paris le 19
janvier dernier et dénoncer ses derniers
jours des relations avec la France qui
sont je le cite ni bonne ni amical
terrible constat de la part de ce pays
traditionnellement tamis le 8 février
c'était au tour de l'Algérie de rappeler
son ambassadeur pour consultation afin
de protester contre l'extfiltration de
la militante algérienne Amira Bouraoui
dans la foulée le pays annoncé qu'il
cesserait de délivrer les indispensables
laissez passer consulaire concrètement
cela signifie que l'Algérie ne reprend
désormais plus aucun de ces
ressortissants expulsés par la France
madame la Première ministre au-delà des
conséquences diplomatiques désastreuses
qui contribuent à faffaiblir toujours
plus notre pays déjà à la sur le
continent africain cette crise avec deux
pays majeurs du Maghreb révèle une fois
de plus l'échec de votre politique
d'expulsion des étrangers en situation
irrégulière
0,2% avec l'Algérie et 2,4% avec le
Maroc comment madame la première minute
dans ces conditions diplomatiques
particulièrement défavorable
comptez-vous réaliser la promesse de
votre Ministre de l'Intérieur
d'atteindre 100% des auqtf engagement
qui apparaît de plus en plus au mieux
comme un vieux au pire comme une
promesse à laquelle personne de sérieux
ne peut accorder le moindre crédit